first you had to draw a diagram and part
one ensue both went on there okay a few
people are confused with their vectors
here so you can see where okay and OB
are the parallelogram law takes you up
to OC this guy down here this blue
vector over here z1 minus z2 from a bar
right
this is z1 so you travel along here you
travel along there and then what you're
adding is negative Z 2 right it said one
takeaway Z 2 is the same as Z 1 adding
negative Z 2 well look Z 2 is putting
you up so negative 2 this point you down
it's got to go down there ok now when
you have a look at part 3 having drawn
those vectors on the only place where
people confuse themselves here is they
use trig these trig it was completely
unnecessary it's not that it's wrong but
because it made things more complicated
students sometimes got it wrong because
they'd made the question trickier or
ever do they got it right they just took
twice as long to get there ok
people hamstrung themselves by drawing
diagrams that were too small you're sick
of us saying this but it's still
happening and you're as a consequence
not able to see what's going on in fear
in here at the origin and how the egg
goes relate to each other ok right
that's how you found those angles do
does anyone have any questions about 13
as a whole
instead of negative its negative you to
remit this part here depending on how
you got there like the important thing
was the reasoning and the calculations
not the number right so I need to see
where basically and I'll have a lot I'll
happily have a look but if you didn't
get that mark that's where I guess it
was lost right let's move into 14 okay
Part A was done
sorry pot a pot one who's done well
there were two ways to go about it you
either just went straight for the
modulus and said okay this is the
distance equation if you went there
there and the vast majority of you did
some of you didn't get okay what is that
modulus mean it's just Pythagoras that's
all the modulus is so some people
included the I when they were doing
underneath the square root because I
don't know well you don't understand how
that the modulus works okay so you got
like an X pin - stuff underneath that
square root which obviously gave you a
wrong number which oh well miraculously
still ended up on 3x plus y minus eight
nice somersaults okay so if you cut that
right that's fine on the other way which
kind of showed more understanding but
you know we're still looking for the
same result is to recognize when you've
got a distance equals a distance that's
a perpendicular bisector like what
you've got is um you've got two points
right and then you say okay well let's
pick out all the points like this guy
and this guy and this guy that are the
same distance from both points that's
what the two sides of the equation means
and of course they join together the
perpendicular bisector of that interval
okay
so that was kind of like a more elegant
way of doing it but either way was fine
okay right now part two was done quite
poorly which was disappointing it was an
easy mark to get in terms of
calculations here's what's going on
right this is the equation of the line
you just found 3x plus y minus 8 equals
0 so Z all of the Zed's that exist are
on this line okay now look at the
question it says 5 a minimum
of modulus of Z as P moves along this
lockers right so you can see the way
I've written it the the modulus of Z is
the distance between that point and the
origin right so therefore you're just
trying to get as close to the origin as
you can because just is the smallest
distance between oh a line and a point
is the perpendicular distance so that's
how you were supposed to use this and
then and then off you go okay now I'm
just a quick note into that extension
one because this came up if you have to
get an equation of a line in general
form right we said you've got to get it
in the right form because you're going
to use it for things like this it's not
some arbitrary thing it's almost always
for the sake of perpendicular distance
or wheel so just watch out if you've got
different numbers there that's why okay
Part B if you got Part B wrong it's
likely because you didn't attempt it
that's a bit of a shame here's the way
that you approach this you don't know
much about this polynomial P of X what
you do know is all of this stuff about
remainders okay so have a look at this
this line here was the critical line
this is a statement of the remainder
theorem okay now what I'm trying to do
is I'm trying to divide through by a
quadratic of X minus 1 X minus 3 right
once you've got a quadratic divides our
quadratic divisor you have a linear
remainder so I've just called that
remainder ax plus B I don't know
anything about a and B but I use the
information the question to help me you
can see there are some linear devices
there which have constant remainders
right and so that's where you can
generate the this pair of simultaneous
equations and then the numbers just fall
out from there okay